this is part two of my conversation with
thomas campbell
who is the author of my big toe a large
theory of everything please watch part
one
in order to get the most out of this
interview enjoy
oh yeah i wanted to ask you specifically
about your experiences when you spoke to
other beings how did they look how did
you interact and
how did you get into that state a couple
questions around that
good and then if
if this if different devices can be used
i remember you mentioned that
you can induce it with certain magnetic
resonances like theta waves
uh no not magnetic so much maybe i don't
know never experimented with magnetic
but
uh i use sound binaural beats
ah right right right and then there's
something called hemisync as well
which i think is robert monroe yeah
exactly so it's pretty much just that
and then asking you mentioned that side
effects are not
able to be replicated and then like why
there's a good explanation for that but
sure okay uh one thing
one of the things i should have told you
is that if you're interested in
a talk about science mostly yeah you
should go to my youtube channel i know
if you've been there yet but i got
thousands of videos there and the one
that you should pick out
is called mbt 2016
mbtla mbtla 2016.
i was in los angeles la in 2016
and gave a two-day talk there the first
day
which was all based on
mbt science of course it was given to uh
what year was that you said
2016. oh okay okay okay
i i was watching one on the marcel
workshop
yeah that's a real general over-the-top
kind of
workshop but if you're just looking for
the science do
yeah the marseille that was in france
so it was in marseille france and that
was a that's a very good
workshop that kind of gives you the the
uh
you know the theory you have quite a bit
of content on your youtube channel
i have over a thousand hours
yeah basically uh who's that there's one
lady that keeps talking to you and it's
the same voice who's that voice
donna donna evening is that the same
lady i'm
i was speaking to over email or is that
a different probably the same lady she's
she and keith her husband keith run mbt
events
she's got a really good voice very soft
very uh
it's a kind of the perfect female
um
soothing pacifying did you happen to
watch eric weinstein
do you have much to comment on with
regard to his theory of everything
oh yeah the both of them yeah i did i
looked at both of those guys and uh
and i can comment on those
okay so why don't i just give you a
general
pitch and just like why don't you
comment you mentioned that you watched
eric weinstein and stephen wolfram
videos so why don't you comment on them
oh okay well of the two
i found um you know wolf rams to be
uh you know the most interesting to me
um
weinstein basically has found a geometry
that at least in his own mind in the
mind of a few people who are close to
him
uh explains of a lot of things
and that's not particularly surprising
but it's
not necessarily new news either in as
much as
given that this is a virtual reality
then the reality is computed
which means it in large extent is is uh
math-based
okay the rule set that allowed this
virtual reality to evolve
is math-based it's a it's basically
deterministic
for the most part and with some
probability and randomness
thrown in for those things that are
probabilistic like radioactive decay
you know it's a natural thing it just
happens to be a random process
so if you have a reality that's
generated by math
then you ought to be able to find
geometries and
other math that kind of look like they
are
explaining the reality you know as
einstein did with his
with his uh space-time it doesn't mean
that those things are fundamental
it doesn't mean that there is this
fundamental space-time out there that's
warped
it just means that he's found some
mathematics
that provides answers
that match pretty well with measurements
right
so it's not so much that it's a thing as
it is a model
it's a model that we use but don't
confuse the model with reality
the model of reality is different so
he's come up now einstein it seems with
some other geometry of course
we don't really know because no paper's
ever been published it's never been
formalized it's kind of
his insider friends know somewhat about
it
and he does but it's still an
unpublished work which in
the science world that means it doesn't
really exist yet you know it's
it's just kind of the ramblings of a of
an individual
until he gets it published it's not real
science
but assuming he does have something and
he is a smart guy and
he knows his math perhaps then
he probably does have something there
that will work
but again not surprising it's a
math-based reality it's computed in a
computer
so it's probably going to have
and it is a probabilistic um
computation for the most for the most
part based on a
deterministic rule set so that's
okay maybe he has something maybe he
doesn't hasn't been published
but not unexpected has
my big toe your big toe been published
at least the theory of everything part
of it not the more
well any of it yeah no the what's been
published is
is the books you're reading those three
books have been published other than
that
there's a thousand hours of video on on
youtube you know but as far as papers go
there's just been one paper that's
that's published in a peer review
physics journal and that's the one that
describes this research
that i'm having done i told you about it
at pomona
by cal poly okay so first i wrote the
paper
and guided peer-reviewed and and howley
his last name is paulie
no no no it's it's a
it's um cal poly is what they call the
school
it's california poly tech is
not a paulie but a poly a p-o-l-y
anyway so
there's not really a lot to say about
weinstein because it's
it's more hearsay than anything else
it's it's second-hand
third-hand hearsay uh but not all that
surprising
now wolfram has a better idea and that's
that he's
he's looking at it from the computing
side of things
which it is a computed reality so you
should again
expect some of what he has uh you know
to
to match
you know if you look at if you look at
simulations there's a lot of common
things about them
so again it's not too hard to find
something that matches pretty well
but his version
seems to be very complicated
you know it's a very complicated process
and
reality if you if you are if you are
trying to explain fundamental reality
then
a good process should be
simple and elegant it shouldn't be
real complicated if it's very
complicated
it's probably not fundamental it's
probably something else
that's basically okam's razor and it's
been a general principle of physics
forever you know the things that are
simple straightforward and elegant
are fundamental things yes you can have
a lot of
of logical um you know
what we call logical consequences that
run off into details
no doubt but the fundamental things are
simple he's awfully complex with what he
does and
i guess i i probably wouldn't have this
opinion except that
uh uh brian whitworth a
fellow in uh new zealand has also
published
a sort of a toe from
the computer side as opposed from the
analytic
math side like weinstein the computer
side process
side of things and his is a lot simpler
and he also
you know it's a lot more elegant and
it's a lot simpler and he also does the
same thing he
derives you know space mass
the uh the what is it the
you know the quantum quantum particles
why they have two-thirds spin
or why you know whatever he he he
derives a lot of constants
in the um standard model and why the
standard model is the way it is when did
that come out
oh that's been out for some years it's
uh
you have to google him he published it
in a peer review paper
uh but i don't think it was primarily a
physics journal so there's probably
i see there's probably a fewer people
that have heard about it but it's a it's
a it's a more elegant
kind of similar approach
are there any other theories of
everything that you find interesting
like brian's um
no brian's is probably the most well
yeah two of them there's two that are
very interesting one's brian's
but the last name of brian one more time
for me if you don't mind whitworth
okay brian whitworth if you google him
you'll probably
dig him up and you'll see he explains
light and he starts with the thing
that he calls a uh plank process so he's
he's uh i you know
he's a math guy but he's also an i.t guy
so he's looking at computer
processing okay that's fine
maybe i can speak to him his playing
process
is a is a is a fundamental thing so
anyway so this is his idea the other
people who are doing
interesting work is a group called
quantum gravity
centered in oh i don't know about 20
miles
north of los angeles and
if you research quantum if you just put
quantum gravity
research on the on the google you'll get
them and the guy who runs that is
is clee irwin all right right quick
clee irwin yeah he runs the quantum
gravity
and he's got a bunch of physicists and
some math people there and he they've
been there for
five or ten years now and clea is the
financier who pays all the bills
so he's been working on this and they've
put some really nice videos together
that if you want
to get a good overview of it he has some
really good
professionally done videos that
kind of explain where he's going with
also it's a geometry
i mean he starts with e8 which is uh
right which is a kind of a shadow of a
lattice if you like
and and he works from there now both of
these guys
whitworth and klee
they are trying to explain
just what we call physical reality
they're not trying to explain the bigger
picture they're not trying to explain
the subjective they only want to explain
the objective world so do they have an
account of consciousness or no
well they do both of them talk about
consciousness
but it's kind of a
a hand-waving thing you know both of
them
uh would say that uh consciousness is
fundamental
and that their their process
is supportive of consciousness being you
know
the fun a fundamental thing so i think
they would both say that and they both
you know consciousness is part of their
thing
but it's not really what they're about
what they're really about
isn't so much consciousness they just
realize that consciousness is the thing
that
you know if you're going to have a child
you need to explain consciousness
you know so they bring so consciousness
is there but it's
not the core thing of their work the
core thing of their work is to explain
this physical universe
you see so again you know
if all you're trying to do is is is try
to uh
join quantum mechanics and relativity
maybe i should call that a tiny toe
and what they're doing is looking at the
whole physical reality whole physical
universe so maybe that's just a little
tao
and then mine is basically you know the
the uh the uh
uh objective and the sub and and the
subjective and consciousness
is at the core you know as the source
and so on so
so then from my viewpoint that's the big
toe because it also talks about
people's experiences and explains those
sorts of things which neither one of
their models attempts to do
so both of them started out on a on a
idea to really derive physics
you know derive physics from
well for whitworth you know from a
computer processing
viewpoint and i'd say he's much simpler
and much more elegant
and that's why i like his better but now
are
any of these fundamentally correct well
they're models
you know and models are judged
not by how correct they are models are
judged by
how many answers they can produce you
know there is no
no this model's the truth and this model
is false it's models provide
uh answers and if they can answer if
they can derive
all the facts that we know of then
they're good models and
qualifiable predictions yeah right right
and falsifiable predictions then they're
good models
so it doesn't matter whether they're
different or strange or bizarre or
whatever it just
matters how do they perform what some of
the signs
sorry for some of the science types who
are listening and now probably it's
about
three and a half hours into this
what is a falsifiable prediction
or set of predictions that your big toe
has oh well it has
quite a few the uh on the uh
non-physical side or on the information
side the subjective side
then it's all experimental but by
individuals
and by groups of individuals you know
the same way you would say that
medicine has you know viability
you know that medicine has truths in it
it's the same thing well you give
somebody a pill
and their headache goes away does that
mean that pill took the headache away
no maybe the headache went away anyway
you need to do statistics and you need
to do probability
and then you need to show significance
of those statistics
before you can say that you've found
something that looks like a fact
so it's a different thing than what they
call the
hard sciences so when you're doing
things that have to do with people
you have to look at your your proof in
terms of
statistics and probabilities and
significance
levels okay so if you if you
or if you or any if you or anybody else
follows the mbt ideas
about what's important to life you know
what our purpose
is here why we're here and so on you
will find
the results as you as you let go of that
fear
you will find your life changing your
relationships will change
all sorts of things will change well
that's verifiable evidence
to you so yes there's a lot of
of um verifiable evidence
there but it's individual because we're
talking about a subjective world
so it's individual to persons now you
can look at
100 persons that do that and see you
know
do you know 50 or 90 or 100 percent
all find similar you know
facts and then you can come up to a
bigger you know an ensemble that's your
statistics can talk about but it starts
with the individuals
over on the the physics side on the
objective side
well yeah i'm doing a set of you know
quantum mechanics experiments now that
are just as
you know as just as um you know just
like any other quantum mechanics
experiments you set up the experiments
you
look at the particles to see what
happens and you're either right or
you're wrong you are able to predict it
or you won't
so the physics that i'm doing has
a couple of experiments that will do
things that are
have never been done before it'll show
us a
piece of reality that nobody's
really seen before in other words people
for the last hundred years have been
coming up with
clever and clever quantum mechanics
experiments
to show you know the the weird science
of quantum mechanics well
the ones i'm coming up with are just
like that too they're going to show the
weird science
and that word science has a good
explanation of why it has to work that
way
and like i said before it'll offer
evidence
and we always talk about evidence we
don't talk about proof
in science last time we talked about
proof in science was when we came up
with newton's laws and then we found out
those laws weren't laws
after all so now we talk about theory
because we realize that
we don't know what the future will bring
what kind of insights and understandings
that will bring so is there a name for
your quantum mechanics experiments that
are happening at that poly institute
um just a name for them
no but they're all talked about people
search for that's
just the the thing i gave you go to
youtube
and look for mbtla mbt
hyphen la 2016. if you look for that
i introduce the experiments there the
whole set of
them i also explain them why they work
and how they work
and the experiments have been run
already
they are in the process of being run
okay and we're maybe within
months a few months of getting the
answers from the very first one
so we're we're chugging we're chugging
on it it took a long time to
gather resources you can't do that on a
dime it's not the kind of experiment
that's easy to do in your basement you
know
it's pretty sensitive stuff and takes
the money
to do the experiment so first i did a
kickstarter
to get the experiments done and
kickstarter
generated 236 thousand dollars to do the
experiments
and we've been working on those ever
since
you know so it's taken a while to find
people who would do them
a lot of scientists well a few
scientists really started and said oh
yeah be glad to do them you're going to
pay for it
great but when they heard the word
consciousness
was somehow connected to it no thank you
we don't want to get involved with that
consciousness
that's not objective that's subjective
and science isn't about subjective
things so we just do science here no
thank you
so we ran into a lot of that so it took
us quite a while before we found a group
of people
who would do it and now it's being done
and we're getting close to the first
answer but the
the niftiest experiments are more
complicated so they'll be done
not first but later but they all are
going to run
out of the same basic set of equipment
that we have so once we get the first
one gone the other ones will start to
come up a lot more quickly
after that so anyway so yeah that is
falsifiable that's just
science like any science and when we do
this we will write another paper
and we will give our results and i'm
sure that will also be published in a
peer review
journal because physics right now
doesn't see virtual reality or i should
say
more in physics terms doesn't see
information-based reality
as a really strange idea a lot of
physics takes that
very seriously matter of fact they know
that that's the only way they can get
right answers in quantum mechanics is
that they look at it as
information based so i'll get that'll be
published in another peer review paper
once we get the
the information so yeah we're doing
science congratulations
i know it's not easy to get even a
thousand dollars on kickstarter let
alone
hundred and sixty that's 200 236.
okay 236 236 so yeah we did pretty well
there were a whole lot of people
who were very excited about that get
that done
because it's it's very interesting you
know it's going to
be is there something that this
experiment predicts that standard
quantum mechanics doesn't predict
yes matter of fact this very first
experiment we're doing
runs very counter to what quantum
mechanics says is true
right now so absolutely can you give us
a brief overview or you just want to
direct people well the brief
now the brief overview of that is that
quantum mechanics started back in ninth
early 1920s
okay and the guys
there you know bohr heisenberg
vigner well einstein was was you know
involved with them he wasn't primary in
that but so on that
that group of people schrodinger um
those guys came up with in a big
conference
in uh copenhagen kind of a
a statement of the results of their
experience this was like the founding of
quantum mechanics so
this is what started quantum mechanics
and after that this explanation
of here's what happened is really what
the copenhagen
meeting was all about presenting results
and here's what it means here's what it
says
and that then was called the copenhagen
interpretation the word interpretation
actually got added later
when people wanted to find something
that was more materialist based they
didn't like the
weirdness of quantum mechanics they
wanted something that wasn't that weird
so it turned into interpretation because
certainly there is some
other understanding of this that's more
materialism-based has more material
causality involved in it
and we just don't know it yet so it was
the copenhagen interpretation
that copenhagen interpretation has been
kind of left behind
and it uh now
the explanation of that double slit
has to do with entanglement
that the slits are entangled with the
particle and the whole experiment is all
entangled with
each other and this is why you know this
is how the information gets captured it
gets captured in this entangled thing
and
so they've they've changed it in order
to
make it more
amenable to materialism basically their
ideas have changed
but nobody's actually done the
experiments to see if that's true
so i looked and looked and looked and i
had some physicists who you know working
physicists in
academia who had access to more than i
had to search you know they have
better databases in their libraries and
things to search they couldn't find any
experiments done either any experiments
on entanglement
no not on entanglement on on the
change where we went from the copenhagen
to the new
the new understanding there wasn't any
experiments done
really to show that that new
understanding
added something valuable and that
copenhagen was
not correct they just went that way
because they had an explanation that
they liked better
so that seems kind of neglectful i
believe
and the reason i got there was because
my explanation that comes out of
consciousness basically supports
copenhagen
and says that the copenhagen had
you know they had the right idea now
they didn't understand the details they
didn't understand the mechanics effects
of how it worked
but what they said about reality and how
their experiments worked out
and why they worked that way was true
so my first experiment is to go back and
do the
and do the experiment that will
differentiate between was copenhagen
right or is this new entanglement
explanation right and that should be
perfectly clear
now what do i expect i expect that
the copenhagen is right and when i
show that in an experiment i expect
that the physicists when they look at it
in the paper will say oh yeah well we
knew that all along
and they will they will do that but yet
they have turned
and made other explanations that are
quite contrary
to that but that's what they all used to
think
you know the copenhagen was the dominant
idea right up until
what 20 years ago or 30 years ago that
was the dominant most accepted idea
about quantum mechanics
but then that they've always had
problems with that
science with that idea
you know with the observer effect with
the measurement problem
with the fact that it makes a difference
whether somebody knows
about the which way data they've always
had an
issue with that because that pulls
consciousness
into the equation the observer
and being very ill at ease with that
they found a way to squeeze that out
using tanglement
entanglement instead but this is a
virtual reality
the reality exists only in the minds
of the players just like world of
warcraft there is no place
where little elves run around and fight
barbarians
it doesn't really exist it only exists
in the minds of the players
if there are no players logged on that
server
serves nothing has no output
the game only exists in the minds of the
players well if the game only exists in
the minds of the players
then it's important that a player
get the in some information because
that's how
things come into that reality the server
sends a player
and says there's a rock here well when
that player sees that rock
there then that rock is now part of the
game
and other players will see that rock
there too
but it's only that rock only exists
because
players get that rock in their
information
right because the computer sends it to
him well that's why you have this
observer
it only reality only comes to us
when it is observed when a player
gets the information so that's the
fundamental reason why
there is this measurement problem and
this observer effect
observer is fundamentally important
because the reality
only exists in the minds of the players
so i get to the same idea
that the copenhagen group did and since
then
like i say physics left that idea behind
because
consciousness and and and physics tests
was like gasoline and water
or oil and water they didn't like it so
they came up with something else but
they came up with that something else
without in other words we have an
alternative explanation
but that alternative explanation doesn't
you know kind of denies this observer
effect and i'm going to show that it
does work the way that
they said about it before so my
experiments
should confirm the copenhagen and
show that the entanglement way of
explaining it
is wrong is not right
so that's that's what they're going to
do so yeah it's going to
you know so that'll be the first
experiment that's the easiest experiment
to do
so good luck with that yeah excited to
see the results
so yeah this theory is not uh you know
just woo-woo that that's made up because
it sounds good and
you know only people with weak minds and
new agers
uh you know have taken seriously this is
real science
and it's based on logic it does real
physics
and it can explain to you why you feel
the way you do
and how your why your life is the way it
is so
that's and what it is you need to do
next what's your purpose here
so it does all of that that makes it a
big toe
rather than a little toe or a tiny toe
when you were speaking to some of the
other beings i don't know what to call
them but what would you call them
well you just you know the the generic
name is
entity okay now so okay
what you're talking about yeah okay i'll
just show you what
you know i'll tell you how that works
and then everything else will become
obvious afterwards
the problem that people have and
probably that you're having too
is that because you have you are so
ingrained
with a kind of a physical viewpoint of
things
it's really hard to let that go
and we reinterpret everything in terms
of
that context and then it doesn't make
sense
so here goes the explanation of you know
when you meet other things most
out of body experiences are basically
the person having the experience logs on
to a single player virtual reality game
okay you know there are sir
single-player games right all games
aren't
multiplayer you know what is it
when you're having a own experience yeah
you're having an experience
now when you have a single-player game
there's often
other characters other entities
in that game it's not like you're there
by yourself there's
npcs in that game and they do all kinds
of things
okay and you your interaction with them
is part of how you learn how to
win the game it's about you and them and
and your skills and so on well most out
of bodies
are single player games so you're
getting a data stream now
directly from the larger consciousness
system and that
that data stream is
defining a reality
reality the single player game is this
one that can be shared with other people
even though it's single-player for
example
let's take fallout 4 it's a game it's a
video game many people can play that
same game
even though it's single player so we're
sharing a similar experience but we're
doing it
on our own yes that can be like that but
these games are often made just for that
individual
they're bespoke they're yeah
i don't know about that bespoke bespoke
they're tailor-made
they're tailor-made yeah they're
tailor-made most of the time
now there are things that happen in
those games and sometimes there are
experiences that people have that are
identical it's like they've taken a
module
here and they've applied it a lot of
places i've had
a matter of fact in my book if you've
read that uh bob monroe and i
had exactly the same scenario right
that's why i was wondering
can it be shared because it seemed like
you spoke to us to similar beings
well now what that was was a
standardized test
bob got that test i got that test
we you get tests here from the larger
consciousness system
why because it would
you have to see this whole this whole
thing that that ties together
we're pieces of consciousness we're
trying we
are parts of the system as we evolve by
lowering our entropy
the system entropy also gets lowered
because we're part of the system
so the system would like us to succeed
in lowering entropy because
it's slower you know it also evolves as
we evolve
its entropy gets lowered as well so it
will often
give us a single single-player game
to help us learn something important to
help us grow up
sometimes it needs to give us some tests
to see just where we are
because otherwise it can't determine
what it is we need to help us grow up if
it doesn't know kind of where we are in
that growth process
so testing is involved just like any
other school
and some of these tests are standardized
so bob got one i got the same test
got exactly the same questions exactly
in the same order
and i've run into at least
six other people that i have shared
tests with not the same one that i did
with bob but others
and we could just share what happened
and it was exactly
the same scenario so it's like we all
had the if you want to put it in other
language we all had the same
dream you know and we interacted with it
how we interacted with it but
the layout was was all exactly the same
so some of it yes
will show up to different people but
mostly
it's a it's a one-off it's for that
person depending on where they are
starting at their level and gives them
challenges with things that they have to
meet with ways that they have to grow so
most
out of body is like that now i went on a
on and out of body with a friend of mine
dennis and i
mentioned him already i think earlier we
went on and out of body together
so that was a two-player game and we ran
into other entities and had
conversations and
did other things during that but that
was a two-player game
so that's possible and if two is
possible and three or four or five or
ten's possible
but most of that just happens in the
margins because that gets more
complicated
and it you know requires more
more scale so basically they're one-off
so when you
go to another reality frame
you're getting another data stream
information defines reality
consciousness is fundamental everything
else
is virtual so when you die
you end up in another virtual reality a
different virtual reality
you don't end up at the source and now
you and
consciousness are sitting down at a bar
together having a conversation
you don't end up in you know some place
where
everybody's smart you just go to another
virtual reality
now to take that one step further if
any space that you're in is experiential
that means you can
experience there it's not a matter of
just existing but you can
do things there's causality you know
things you can change you can have an
experience there
if you can have an experience there it's
a virtual reality
experience requires context
you can't have an experience if there's
no context that defines the experience
context is created by rules
rules create the context you know like
if i just say okay
kurt let's go play a game all right you
go first go
well you don't know what to do because
there's no context there's no rules
right so there's no game
rules can spontaneously emerge right for
example with children when they play
they often don't specify the rules and
they come up with the game
yeah it's a collective agreement but now
we can talk about collective
consciousness and other sorts of things
but uh i'll try to stay well let's try
to stay focused we zinged around so much
that
um it's just such an interesting we
start down this path and get about third
of the way there and
then we go someplace else and get about
a third away there and zing someplace
else
so anyway your question your question uh
my question was essentially it's about
being other seeing other entities now
so it's the way that i understand it
they're data streams you see
everything's a data stream so when we
think about i talked to an entity well
you know where they come from where do
they live you know do they live in
houses you know do they eat do they poop
you know what
what's going on there are these really
people like us but
now it's information everything
consciousness is fundamental
it creates information reality
exp experiential things like
experiencing another being
talking to another being this is that's
an experiential thing
that happens in a virtual reality it's
information based
everything is information based so
this reality we call the physical
universe it's just information
it only exists in the heads of the
players okay
and you go out of body and you just
basically log on to some
other virtual realities it's like going
from sims to world of warcraft to
no man's sky you know you just log on to
a different
a different you got it you've got a
modern game right there though yeah so
you're not stuck in 2000's anymore
yeah all my video knowledge is watching
my children play when they were
like teenagers they're all in their
middle of no man's sky is a great
example because it's procedurally
generated on the spot
right which is the way you know reality
is procedurally generated
right on the spot for the most part it's
a probabilistic thing so
yeah that's that's much more efficient
that way
so in any case so if you
let go of the idea that reality is
real stuff it's mass and and you know
the stuff really here
really exists and you see it as
information
than out of bodies and dreams
and all of these things where we find
ourselves in
daydreams as well you know not just
night dreams but daydreams we find
ourselves in some other reality
it's just another data stream now we are
consciousness
and we can create information
information is non-physical
information is not a physical thing it's
a non-physical thing information
is separate from data data is a physical
thing data you transfer things in data
information
is the is the meaning the content the
significance
of that data it takes a consciousness to
have
information because the consciousness
interprets the data
into its reality into some kind of
meaning or content without a
consciousness to interpret the data well
it's just a
it's a piece of paper with a lot of ink
squiggles on it
that's not information that's data but a
consciousness looks at those ink
squiggles on that page and oh
that's information you see so
realities created by
information our sense data produces
information which creates this reality
all right well it's the same with the
elf the else sense data
quote unquote you know the things that
it would sense the things it sees the
things it feels the things it hears
well that's all information and the
player gets that information
the player sees what the elf sees and
what the elf hears and so on if the
player has a headset on and the player
is watching the screen
so at sense data so the sense data you
know of the elf is sent to the player
and the player experiences what the elf
experience is sort of
but now with consciousness it's much
more embedded it's a
100 percent involvement so anyway
so now we talk about being so what is a
being a being is something you can talk
to
it's something that responds to you it's
something you can carry on a
conversation with it talks as opposed to
a rock
which doesn't talk back in order to get
to these
single-player games these other worlds
let's say
does one have to have a lower entropy
already or
it doesn't matter anyone can experience
it well
anyone can experience it and a lot of
people do
but if that's the case and they don't
have low entropy
it's extremely haphazard it just happens
when it happens
and sometimes it does sometimes it
doesn't it's just one of those things
that is totally out of their control
sometimes they have a out-of-body
experience sometimes they have things
now
some people learn to control it
reasonably well but
as you lower your entropy the ease with
which you can control it
grows it gets easier and easier
when you first learn to meditate it
takes you 15 minutes to get into a good
meditation state eventually you can get
into a good meditation
state in a tenth of a second it doesn't
take long same without a body
same with exploring and being in other
reality frames and getting information
out of databases
you can do that in fractions of a second
and you can parallel process
in more than one reality at a time so i
can be
talking to you and you can be telling me
about how your poor mother fell down the
steps and you know hurt herself and
could i help heal her
and while i'm having a conversation with
you i'll be doing the healing at the
same time at another
at another level i'll be working in
another conscious
of both in some manner yeah conscious of
both
it's not that hard to do i mean it's
like multitasking or is it different
no it's like multitasking it's a similar
thing i mean you see
people go into a sports bar and they'll
have five different things showing on a
big screen you know five different sport
events
well with a little practice you can
watch all five of them and hardly miss
anything
you know but it is a zero-sum game you
can you can't spend 100
of your attention on anyone you have to
spread your attention over
over all of them it's the same way with
this so yes you can do that because you
can
grab hold of data streams let go of them
be here be there and it's all a matter
of focusing your intent
and practicing this and most people can
do some of these things with you know
six months worth of practice i mean it
doesn't
it's not that hard to do it's not oh
yeah speaking of transcendental
meditation is it better for me to do it
20 minutes twice a day or
once for one hour a day so that's three
times as long
it's probably better to do it uh twice a
day for 20 minutes each time and
if that gets easy and you really enjoy
it and get a lot out of it then you can
maybe do it for
30 minutes twice a day i'll tell you a
bit of my experience
so firstly it's been only a month and a
half and i haven't done it consistently
but the times that i find when i do it
longer the shorter times i get virtually
nothing out of it
and most of the time i get virtually
nothing out of it but some of the times
i get
it's more like i'm in a place where i
feel like i'm floating
it's almost like i'm swimming slowly and
i imagine like analogize it to a turtle
just like
hello this is interesting and then
there's
also some clarity not just some but
it's strange i have a distracted mind
and so it's calming some of that down
but it takes
quite a bit of time to calm it down
first of all so that's why i have to do
it for longer that's why i was asking
maybe one hour
better for me for you it for you it may
be yeah
like i say it's processed now eventually
you can do it very quickly
but in the beginning it's a it's a slow
trip for most people they constantly
have thoughts coming into their mind
that they need
to let go of and until they can sit for
say a half an hour with no
no thoughts in their mind at all let's
imagine that my mantra was
shima just for the sake of this okay i
don't know if i'm saying it properly am
i supposed to just repeat she mushy
am i or am i supposed to time it with my
breath or is that a mistake because now
i'm
consciously timing it with my breath i
find it it happens
automatically it goes with my brain
right so the thing is
you want to let your intellect sit down
and be quiet
so if synchronizing it requires your
intellect to do it
you have to think about it to do it then
it's a problem
you want things to just happen so you
just say your mantra
and it's you you think it you don't say
it out loud you just think your mantra
and you think it and what you're doing
is you're filling your awareness
full of non-operable junk
a mantra a nonsense thing
and you say that and that fills your
mind
your wife's real cute with her little
ears up on top of her head i know i told
her can you just sneak by
and not say anything don't even
acknowledge me usually we kiss before
she goes but
i said i'm gonna be in this oh you
should have kissed her
that's all right you you're you can
always edit that out but yeah
anyway the little ears were cute yeah uh
okay
so where were we um yeah if it takes to
take it to all the time it needs if it
takes you a half an hour
just to get to the point where it's
getting productive then
take that time because stopping before
it gets productive is not good
you need to get a time when it's
productive but i'll challenge you with
something else that when you're that
turtle
and you're just up there and you're kind
of drifting and whatever
now if you have an intent that you would
like to
see what was going on in your
mother-in-law's house or your parents
house
or with your best friend who lives
someplace else what is he doing now
have that intention and just let things
come into your mind
yeah okay help me out with the
difference between intention and
intellect because
i imagine that if i was to intend it
then it would be as if i'm using my
intellect
no yes that's a problem if you're using
your intellect that will
destroy it and that's the hardest thing
for you to get through
is to get your intellect to sit down and
be quiet because you are
an intellectual you lead with your
intellect your intellect does all the
judging and the assessing
and so on and you have a really hard
time
engaging in anything without your
intellect leading
so your problem will be your intellect's
always going to jump
in front to take charge because that's
how you live your life
so that will be your most difficult
thing but if you can let that intellect
just
be there and just experience
don't judge it don't assess it don't
analyze it
just experience it now that sounds easy
but it's hard when your intellect jumps
in let's say that you do and you're just
a turtle and you might say
well is there anybody out there i could
communicate with
a thought and something would come you
get some answer back
and as soon as you get the answer back
you go what what was that
who was that did i just make that up you
see your intellect jumps
right to it but if you can keep that
intellect from jumping in
and just experience let it go wherever
it goes
it doesn't matter what the content is it
doesn't matter whether it's all
ridiculous
just let it go wherever it goes however
it wants to go there
you're a scientist you just want to know
what's going to happen if i just let
this thing run
not judge whether this is real or
whether this is helpful or anything else
just experience and if you can do that
then at that point where you're the
turtle drifting you can have an intent
and to see something somewhere and
that means you're remote viewing now
or you can have an intent to look at
somebody's
health and say that they you see like a
humanoid
body that's all white and you can say
the white is healthy and the black
anything black or dark is unhealthy and
the more unhealthy it is the darker
it is so a light gray thing would be
somebody that's maybe
uh you know not feeling too well has a
cold uh
the flu or something and maybe a big
black spot right here would be a
you know a tumor in a lung or in a
breast or something so
anyway you can do these things with your
mind is there an activity that you find
works particularly well for
somewhat beginners like myself for
example you just mentioned
go in and say is there anyone here i
could talk to and then see what happens
are there any more suggestions well yes
the biggest suggestion is
start with an intention of why you want
to do this
if why you want to do it is just to
experience
reality experience the bigger picture if
one exists you'd like to experience it
you know if that
is your point that's okay but it's even
better
if you'd like to grow up you'd like to
become more you'd like to have a bigger
picture you'd like to increase
your understanding you'd like to to know
is there
and it can't be okay so for example it
can't be
how can i solve this particular problem
i can't go in with that intention
because that would automatically be
engaging my intellect from the game it
would be
it would be much harder to do because
that would do you now
man one of your first times with the
debugging
is inspirational to me yeah i'm not
saying it's it's uh
even hard to do i'm saying it'll
probably be hard for you to do
so i wouldn't ex that you start that way
that's because your intellect will get
into that problem right away but once
you get to the point where you can get
into this
intuitive state or being level state and
not an intellectual state
then there's all kinds of things that
are open to you
that you can do and yes solving problems
are one of them
you can you can do things like that so
developing what you're doing now what i
encourage you to do
is to develop your intuitive side spend
some time like you've spent developing
your intellectual side
developing your intuitive side and it
will take a little time and some
practice
but you have to do that by getting your
intellect
to sit down and be quiet and not
interrupt
not jump into it you have to just plain
experience in other words instead of
doing
you have to just be you and your mind
just being which see
that's why everybody starts with
meditation that's the end point of your
meditation is to just be
not to be thinking about anything just
to be to exist kind of the descarte
moment right
you know i am i exist
i have a i have mind and if you can
settle into that state which is what
you're learning
through your meditation practice and
then you can maintain that state without
your intellect jumping into the game
you will be able to do all of the
paranormal things rather easily
they're not that hard to do and
eventually getting into that intuitive
space
will be easy because you've done it
hundreds of times you'll have done
evidential things hundreds of times and
you'll see that well
these times when i kind of entered it
this way it worked
really well and these times when i
it was different you had a different
approach to it a different attitude and
so on it didn't work
so you will learn what works what
doesn't work
so working with evidential stuff is an
important way to start
things that you can verify later
and one of the main reasons to meditate
is simply to calm down to remove the
distractions
so does that mean that like for example
later today i have a massage
should i be meditating when i get my
massage i imagine that if i try i would
just be pulled out by the frequent
pain well
you should probably to maximize the
effect of the massage
you should be with that massage in other
words your
your your mind your your awareness
should be
with the body in the sense that you're
not thinking about anything
but you're feeling everything every
touch every push
and you want your mind you don't want to
feel this lady man she hurts like heck
man
you wouldn't it's way too much i have to
distract myself from that
well tell her to ease off then say no
not so hard there makes her go harder
i'm just kidding yeah i like i like a
fairly hard
massage myself i like it if it hurts
good
as soon as i say that it's painful she
said oh great we have some friends and
then she goes a little bit harder
quickly as an aside i had to have to
interrupt and let you know that in south
etobicoke if you're in south etobicoke
in toronto
and you want the best massages at least
the best massage that i've ever had from
a registered massage therapist
that is an rmt someone who can write a
note so that you can claim it under
health insurance
she fixes parts of my back and my
shoulder that i had no idea
needed remedying the best massages that
i've ever had are with her
i'm getting nothing from this
testimonial nothing at all no free
massages nothing
i just believe in her a tremendous
amount she's a tiny lady who
happens to be extremely strong for
whatever reason almost every person that
have referenced to her
loves her and becomes a repeat client so
if you like deep tissue massages and you
can handle pain
then email toe indiefilmtio.com
and i'll text you or email you her
number but she's
wonderful the best massages in your mind
what you have to focus on
is that her hands are releasing
stress her hands are releasing knots
knots are little balls of stress and
that you are going to feel better you're
going to be
better you're going to be healthier your
immune system is going to work better
you physically are going to be more in
tune without all these little stress
knots in it and if you see that soon you
feel that pain
feel that stress being pushed
out of your body imagine
that muscle instead of being knotted up
like that just relaxing
and am i repeating the mantra at this
point or this has nothing to do with
transcendental well
it does have it's all related but you
don't have to repeat the mantra
you can that helps keep you in that
space yes you can keep saying the mantra
and then as you feel things yeah as you
feel things then
then have the intention that all those
things you feel
are making you healthier they're all
making you better you're getting rid of
toxins and poisons and
and knots of stress and tension
and it's all going to help you think
better and be better and move better
so now you translate that pain
into oh that feels like i'm getting
better that feels like i'm getting rid
of stress
and when you have a positive attitude
toward it rather
oh that feels like pain you know that
hurts
the more you think about it the more you
think about it the more it hurts
change the way i frame it change the way
you frame it frame it
posit it positively but do it
not intellectually but just because
you're floating there like a turtle and
a turtle and turtle getting a turtle
getting a massage
but your intention is that that massage
is a
is a step toward a better you and better
health it could put your
positive intent to it and then all
through the massage
you are raising the probability of that
massage
giving you much better health because
your intention modifies the future
probability
so anyway yes you can
engage that way now eventually
when you've practiced this for i don't
know you're very left brain
like me i was like that i was a
physicist you know physicists are very
left brained very
logical process oriented so though you
said that you were able to get to that
state fairly easily at least in your
first time because you'd remember that
you'd done it when you were young yeah
yeah i fell into that very very easily
when i picked it up again in graduate
school
but in any case and i came into this
world a very right-brained
little guy and i knew that i had to
develop
the the logical side that i had already
a
pretty strong intuitive side but i
needed a logical side
and it wasn't easy i worked very very
hard to
develop that intellectual side and that
logical side
and eventually it became easy you know
if you work on something that
it gets easier and easier so i've
already
started this life more intuitive
had to develop the left side so that's
my own thing but
a lot of people see i see a lot of
people like you
who are connected with my book because
it is the only on-ramp to a bigger
picture
for logical process people it is a
logical
uh process so quite a few people
when i teach people how to do paranormal
things
quite a few of them are just like you
they are
very left brain dominant very logical
process dominant
but all of them have some great
successes
after a while a process like when you
teach them do you start with
transcendental and then
you just do a regimen of do that twice a
day and then come back and then
after two weeks try this one out try
healing your
spouse if you want to uh if you want to
go through
the process it's easy to do again
everything i do i try to make it free
and you can go to my youtube site
and look for the very latest tmi
video tmi the monroe institute okay i
went to the monroe institute just as a
facility
they wanted me they asked me to come
there so i did and i gave one of my
courses
telling people how to experience the
larger system
and the reason i give those courses i re
i
refrain from giving them though i was
asked many times
because i don't really want to be mr out
of body
or mr paranormal i'm a i'm a physicist i
want to be taken seriously so i kind of
low key that but on the other hand i
tell people that if it's not your
experience it's not your truth so go go
learn
but i don't really give them a path to
do that so they
they caught me up short on that little
piece of logic and i started offering
these courses to help them do
that so if you go to the youtube find
the last tmi which i did last august
so you'll find it august 2020 and look
at that
and you will have the whole 2019 you
mean right unless you did it during
the coronavirus yeah 2019 it'll be 2019
right
so when you when you find that one
that's the whole course
now all you have to do to make the
course complete
is go to mbt events and i think for 20
bucks or 25 bucks you can get a a set of
the
binaural beats that i used
during that course for those people
and basically the way the format's set
up is that i
talk to people and explain to them
what's happening
and what's going on are those binaural
beats related to hemisync or
is that completely independent no they
are related i'll tell you that story
next
okay bring that back up so so you get
those binaural beats and i think there's
like 13 of them and maybe one thrown in
to help people sleep if they
want but there's 13 there and you'll go
through a process i'll explain
give you the understanding give you
pointers and things to do and things to
not do
and then you go take a binaural beat
session which is 50 minutes
and go experience go try to five zero
or five one five is it fifty
fifty minutes yeah five zero 50 minutes
a little less a little less than an hour
yeah and that's then you come back
and then you say well it didn't work
nothing happened or
oh i got this or i got that what does
that mean and then there's questions and
the people who were there will ask me
questions
and they'll ask me things and i explain
to them i'm the coach basically because
i've been there and i experienced all
these things so i know what they're
going through
so i coach them and i say well here's
what the problem was you need to
you know not do this or here's where
your intellect got into it
and i give them some help then it's time
to go listen to another one
so they go back out and do it again and
we keep doing that for
four days five days how many times in
one day
four times in a day interesting so
there's gonna be
i think it's well some was four when i
was a tmi i think it was four times in a
day other places sometimes it's three
it depends on the course and how many
days it is and so on
so that's
that is the course so you can for 25
bucks
you can get a complete course that costs
2500 bucks
and the only thing you're missing is the
ability to ask your own questions
but then keith and donna who run my
events they just started
with a what they called an add-on course
which means
people like you could go spend the 25
go get that that video actually do the
course
and then we'll get together for
what uh six hours a day for three or
four days in a row and then you get to
ask your questions
and we do a little bit of we do a little
bit i think i did healing and remote
viewing with the people
while we were there but basically this
is the chance you've already done the
work you've done the course
this is the chance to come actually
ask your questions if you have them so
you know for 25 bucks you can get a 2500
course
just uh it's not quite as good as being
there but it's probably a 95
of it it's pretty close to being there
i'll leave the link
i'll display it right now on screen as
well as put it in the description
so people can go check it out themselves
too lastly oh you're mentioning hemisync
and the relationship between that and
binaural beats
okay let hemisink dennis and i um
came up with the ca ran into well
actually dennis saul in a scientific
american back in 1960 something
it was uh published in scientific
american that binaural beats and trained
brain waves
so if you have bio a binaural b i guess
i should tell you listeners if you have
a pure tone
in this era pure tone in that ear and if
the tones are slightly different let's
say four hertz different
then if you do those in air you'll get a
four hertz speed you know here's the
speaker and here's a speaker and they're
looking at each other
you'll get a four hertz speed so a four
hertz beat would be something like
one two three four one two three four so
that's what would happen now you put it
with headphones you stick it in your ear
particularly these kind of headphones
little earbuds are good and you stick it
in your ear
now pure tone here pure tone here four
hertz difference
and the signals get through the audio
nerves down to the corpus callosum which
is the membrane between the two
hemispheres
and at that point you actually generate
a beat frequency
inside your brain as opposed to
inside the air the medium for the beat
frequency is
your brain it's oscillating neurons or
what
it's well that is not
we don't know that for sure but we know
that if you put
uh eeg on that measures brain waves
and if that's four hertz your brain wave
energy will tend to move to the four
hertz
that's what they mean by brainwave
entrainment now to say that whether it's
you know shaking neurons or something
that's
physiologists who want to know the
correlation between what's happening in
the brain and what
what comes out of an eeg i wouldn't
speak to that
but in any case it entrains brain waves
in the sense that
your brain wave is like energy on the
vertical axis
and frequency on the horizontal axis
so you generally have different kinds of
frequencies popping off
up and down all over the place okay now
you meditate
and when you meditate the the energy
under the the area under the curve
of all these things going up and down
the energy there
it uh it tends to move
toward the alpha state and the theta
state
okay alpha brainwave so they put these
things on
on monks who really good at meditating
just for people watching i use this
which
which is supposedly to help the gamma
and then it does have a theta setting
yeah okay so that's so that's anyway
that's the idea of a binaural beat
and it doesn't drain brain waves and
they know that meditators when they
meditate
they slide the energy slides from all
over the place to
down to the theta low alpha theta region
okay so that's if you want something to
help you
meditate then you take a binaural beat
of about four hertz because four hertz
is right there in
in the middle of theta region if you
just want to relax then you
have a her you know a difference
frequency of say uh
eight or ten hertz which is low alpha
and now you just now you just mel out
you see so and if you want to wake up
then you send it up to
you know 20 hertz or 40 hertz or
something else and now you're
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed so
it's a brainwave entrainment now you
have to cooperate with it it's not that
it forces you
to do something it just encourages you
toward a
an area you if you don't cooperate with
it it doesn't
uh it isn't going to affect you so it's
not not something scary that's
that's taking over your mind so it's an
ancilla it helps you
yeah it just helps you so if you're not
a good meditator yet
then it's a it's a tool that will help
you
meditate and it'll help you keep that
meditation state
but like all like all such uh
crutches you need to know when to take
them off
you know you if you put those little
little training wheels on your bicycle
when you're five years old and learn to
ride a bike
well they'll help you because they'll
keep you from falling over and
and getting hurt so but
if you're ever going to be good at
riding a bike you got to take those
little wheels off because they prevent
you from leaning into a turn i see
so it's the same with this you can use
the binaural beats
as much as you need them to maintain
that
that intuitive state down in the theta
region
but eventually you need to be able to do
it on your own
and take the headphones off so it's not
something to do forever but it's
something to do as long as you
you know as long as you need that help
then you should use it
so it's a good tool so anyway dennis
read the article we were working
at the lab and anything that a trained
brain waves was interesting to us
because we were trying to figure out how
to reproduce bob states
you know make them happen in a naive
subject so to speak
so we went right out to the lab and
started playing with binaural beats
and found out they were very effective
in producing
uh you know the states that are very
effective for
going out of body which is the theta
state which is just before you get to
delta which is
like you know you lose consciousness so
anyway we found that out and um
bob took that binaural beat he was gone
at the time and then some
weeks later he came back we showed him
what we'd done and told him well it
works better than anything we've tried
so far
and he liked it as well he experimented
with it
and then he took some binaural beats and
added them
to this little uh kind of surfy sound he
had that had kind of a four hertz
modulation
but it wasn't binaural and it was
relaxing but it didn't have the power of
the binaural beat
he added the binaural beat to it and
named it hemisink and got a patent on it
so that's so that's tmi's patented
you know um sound that they use to
encourage people to be in a good
and stay in a good meditation state it's
called
you know it's that so you can buy things
from
from monroe institute tmi and it'll have
you know that in it hemisync and
the reason he called it hemisync is they
had a
a brain scan you know sort of like a cat
scan thing things that look at your
your brains and the energy and areas
that light up and don't light up
and when you listen to the sound or if
you can
meditate without it either way you'll
find that the two hemispheres which are
scattered all over yeah start to get
caught
they start to get symmetric they start
to look the same
and so that's where the hemisink came
from he used the
the hemisphere sinking sinking the
hemispheres is that
is the hemi saint for the people
watching i'm sure they're thinking okay
earlier you said that you can access
npmr
fairly easily now because you've
practiced it and npmr
affords you greater access to
information
so is there something that you can do
please tell me if this is uncouth but is
there something that you can do
even if it takes two minutes or whatever
in order to give some evidence for
someone who's watching
that you're accessing a place where
there's information that you wouldn't
have access to otherwise
so for example to not to make this a
carnival trick at all
but to say my birthday or my birth
month or or whatever it could be yeah
it's it's it's not uncouth but it
doesn't it's not really effective
and it doesn't work i've been there and
done that and
it doesn't work so much and here's why
it's all intellectual it doesn't help
anybody if you want to see
evidence of people being able to do
these things
i mean real stuff that's written out you
know not just some guy
because if you and i do something you
know and i do some kind of thing with
you and whatever
well you and i could just be
collaborating on that you know
we could you and i are what a
co-conspirator
it doesn't really prove anything
to people so they have to experience it
themselves or it's not their truth
reading about it listening to it seeing
people do it
unless it's done with them unless
they're part of it
then it just doesn't help it doesn't
help them grow
at all it may get a gee whiz out of them
but it doesn't really help
so what they will what they can do if
they really are serious about wanting
evidence
to see it yeah then where they what they
should do
is go to a remote viewing
site now there's lots of remote viewing
sites but go to ones where they're
really serious about it where they study
it
where they take remote viewing as a as a
science
they're working on it get involved with
them in other words
are there any that you recommend there's
dozens of them
there's lots of them you can find groups
i mean you no there hasn't heard of dean
raiden
yeah i've heard of dean rayden dean
rayden does real experiments
look at dean raden's work you read his
book he's a good
he's a good guy he does real experiments
and he's very serious about his
his protocols and his science so he's
written a bunch of books read his books
and that would give you
evidence but again people read the books
and they say yeah well he could just be
making all this up
and you'll go to a remote viewing site
and you could say yeah but all these
people maybe they're just making it up
so it it won't help unless you find a
good remote viewing site because you can
call deraden he probably won't let you
just
come in his lab you know that would be
probably it's not going to do that for
very many people
but anyway so the reason it won't work
is because people won't believe it
no the reason it's not worth doing is
that people won't believe it it's just
not a good idea
for one reason and two like i say i try
to keep low profile
on the on the weird side of things so
the more i do things like that that is
what i get remembered for
i can talk about the nature of reality
and science and quantum mechanics for a
hundred hours
and i do one paranormal stunt and
that is how i know that just puts me in
the light that i don't want to be in
i'm still a serious scientist and i need
to get
serious attention in the scientific
world
so i don't want to emphasize that part
of what i do
but go to a remote viewing site make
look at ones get the sense that they're
really
real people doing things join them visit
the site spend
spend a week spend a month or two you
know
and what following they're following
their sessions filing their things go to
a
course there's hundreds of courses on
remote viewing
you have to get involved yourself if you
don't get involved yourself
it's not going to affect you one bit
the reason i asked for some
recommendations is because clearly there
are some people who are scammers
and then clearly there are people who
well not clearly but the
claim is that there are people who are
not so then
how does one disentangle there's not
that many
scammers you're not going to find
scammers putting up a remote viewing
site where a bunch of people are
pretending to remote view
that i think would be a probably a very
low probability if you have a bunch of
people
spend some time interact with them send
them emails
do they seem like they're wild and crazy
and just trying to convince you and
of something or they're just doing
science and you can
you can watch if you like you know that
sort of thing you have to come to that
assessment
yourself and yes that takes a little
time
and if i were to give you a site i don't
really have any but if i gave you one
then that's not all that helpful because
i'm a weird guy giving you some weird
sight of course i'd give you some scam
site where they would convince you of
what i wanted you convinced of
see it just that doesn't work you have
to go do the work yourself you have to
go to the site you have to talk to the
people
you have to get some sense of how
sound they are how serious they are
about remote viewing and about
you know the judging the remote views
and look at their targets they'll show
you well here
here were the targets and here's what
the remote viewers got
and you'll see that some of them are
sketchy and some of them are
surprising or amazing well
logic says that if a person can just one
person can do it once
then it's possible after that it's only
a matter of
learning you know growing it yeah i mean
the possibility of it is easy to come by
you just have to take some time and do
it for yourself so it's your search
you talk to the people they've helped
you maybe you went to the course
and you take a course from them if they
teach courses
and eventually you'll be doing it but if
all you do is meditate
find out become a turtle every once in a
while and in that turtle
come up with some things you'd like to
see someplace and check and see if you
see them
and if you can just keep your if you can
just
experience i just want to experience
i'm not going to judge it i'm not going
to say oh is this right what does that
mean you know i'm not going to analyze
it i'm just going to let the experience
come
if you can do that then you'll find
that you will be amazed at the
information you will pick up
and you'll get better at it over time
and then
you won't see it you won't have that
question is it real
because you'll know because you did it
and that's the only way to know for sure
not your experience not your truth so
rather than
you know put on a show that doesn't
really help anybody grow up
i encourage people to go find out go do
it yourself and remote viewing
is easy healing somebody with your mind
is even easier than remote viewing
because there's more uncertainty
involved
your ability to do these things is tied
directly to the uncertainty surrounding
what it is that you're doing
and we could explain all of that too but
in in any case there's a connection but
because
what what bodies are hugely complex
things and the things that they can do
leaves always a lot of uncertainty you
know people do
have stage four cancer given three
months to live
and get rid of it it goes away
that doesn't happen a lot but it does
happen it's possible
so that's uncertainty
you see that helps you be able to work
in the in the health area so
probably healing with your mind is one
of the simplest things anybody can do
but now instead of remote viewing you
either get it right or get it wrong
see what you can go you can go to a site
and practice remote viewing there's lots
of sites you google remote viewing
targets
and basically you'll go to that site and
the site will give you a number
and that number is associated with
target so let's say there's a hundred
thousand
pictures and you get a number that's
associated with one of those pictures
and your job is to look at that number
and remote view the picture that's
associated with it
remote viewing is just getting data out
of a database
have you just for yourself not for
anyone else but have you done that
or you've gone to a website and then
consistently been able to see the
pictures associated with the numbers
yeah i've been able to do that where i
would consistently do that now if i
practiced at it a lot
i get better at it because i don't do
those things
much i don't find a lot of need to do
those those are things i did
what 30 years ago when i was learning
and growing and i needed to understand
and i was practicing and getting better
once
you have it it's not really that
practical a tool it's not something you
really
need to do i recall you saying that
children
have an easier time getting to npmr is
that correct right oh
yes children have a much easier time and
the reason is they don't have that big
intellect blocking them
does that not mean that we can use that
as a test where we ask children to
remote view for us and then see
if they're able to predict it better
than adults
you could you could do that i suspect if
you you'd have to get maybe a couple
hundred children and run them through a
very specific kind of
situations and see what sort of things
they do
they're very imaginative as well most
children when they meet an adult
what they try to do is tell the adult
whatever the adult wants to hear
so if they get the idea that you know
you'd like them to
tell you something you know like there's
must be something in that room and what
is it well they'll go right away with
their imagination trying to figure out
what it is because they want to give the
right
answer we we kind of teach them that
rather than just be open to
whatever answer but yes in general if
you got lots of kids you'd find that
they were
generally much better than that than a
group of a thousand adults the children
would get it right
more often sure right sure enough anyway
you go to the site you wrote
remote view then you type your number
back in and up comes the picture
so now you got what you wrote down i see
it i said that's what you forgot
and then there's the picture now so you
got an immediate did i get it right
did i get it wrong and how much of it
did i get right did i get part of it
right
you know because you're not just review
remote viewing the whole picture you're
remote viewing
elements of it and aspects of it and
feelings of it you know what does it
smell like what does it sound like
is it happy is it sad is it big is it
small
you're doing all of those kinds of
things because as a beginner
that's easier than what's the picture
look like
that's harder for you to grok when
you're a beginner
when you're just starting you break it
down into all kinds of little things
and you'll surprise yourself how much of
it you can get
when you do that okay and that's the
place where you start
and it's easy i mean you just get the
site it's free
and you get immediate feedback of
whether you got it right or wrong
now with healing you don't get immediate
feedback
okay you heal you know if you want sick
people for targets go talk to your
grandmother you know she knows people
who aren't feeling well
and then you can ask her well you know
how's susie doing now is she feeling any
better and grandma
will tell you perhaps so you need to get
feedback
but now you have to do it hundreds of
times
and start looking at statistics and
start looking at the
the uh the difficulty of the case is it
something that's chronic or is it
something that's just minor like a
headache
so that kind of thing now you can get
some immediate feedback on diagnosis
where you look at someone and just see
what's wrong with them
and if you get the diet then you can ask
grandma you know what the diagnosis is
what did susie have
so there's there's lots of ways for you
to practice
that don't take a lot of effort on your
part
or any money just go spend some time
doing it and your key problem
is going to be your intellect the key
problem is going to get that intellect
to
sit down while you just open yourself to
whatever
comes whatever happens and
another hint is that the database is
fast you're really getting the state out
of a database and by the
you know when you have your intention is
how you do the query
where you send out that intention and
instantly
the result comes in it's not like google
that takes
you know a half a second before the
results come in
it comes back instantly so a lot of
people will put out their intention and
then they'll get ready for the result
but the results already been delivered
and they missed it
yeah so you have to be aware that it's
coming very very
quickly so the first thing the first
idea that comes into your mind the first
sensation
that's interesting what else would
people be aware of because that's a
tidbit i haven't heard before
yeah take the very first thing um
well the second or the second thing that
i would share with you break it up into
pieces don't just try to
see the whole picture okay break it up
into pieces what does it feel like
you know what's that what's the ambience
what are the basic colors
you know is it red or yellow or green or
white is it a
or is it rainbow colors does it have a
cell
a smell does it have a a sense of uh you
know is it light or dark
yeah those kinds of things and what are
the elements say in your mind say well
what are the architectural elements
and you may just get a picture of a
circle so you put a circle
and you can say well what else so do it
in stages what else
oh a line over here all right put the
line over there
anything else oh yeah zigzag line down
this side
and just keep doing that until you say
is there anything else and you'll get
nothing
well then you're done and when you get
nothing and you've gone through all of
those things then you look at your lines
and zigzags and circle
and look at your picture and see if
there's any relationship between what
you did in that picture
now the probability that you're going to
get things that really fit that picture
is probably what
one in ten thousand you know i mean
there's all these pictures and the
pictures are
are not like pictures of fog these are
very you know they have a lot of things
in the pictures they're very clear
elements they've been picked for remote
viewing for that reason
so it's not likely that you're going to
get
say 75 80 percent of all the elements
right
yes you might get one of them you might
get treated just by
just by being lucky but you consider it
a
a success if you get you know what
half of them can people use this to win
the lottery
or to make money they can try but it
mostly doesn't work
because because the system doesn't allow
it
because it's not on the path of low
entropy it's a path of high entropy
so the system does not allow it matter
of fact there was a
there was a story i read
that a fellow who was very good at this
and i think he did it professionally he
was probably one of those people that
you know stands up and picks people out
of the audience and tells them about
their grandmother or something like that
he was somebody who was very talented
about getting data out of the databases
so he did a he did the
the winning lottery number and he wrote
it down
and he didn't buy ticket or anything he
just wrote it down
and he got it he wrote it down correctly
and he did that again he did it several
times where he predicted the lottery
correctly so he said okay
i'm going to buy a ticket this time and
he'd predict you know what it was going
to be
and he bought the ticket and
he didn't win the lottery but had all
the numbers right
except they were all off by one digit
all the way through
well that was just the system telling
him nice try
but you know no banana you know you're
you're not going to
to do that so it wasn't like he was
far off i mean he was far off every
digit was wrong but it was always wrong
by just one
this seems to me to be incontrovertible
evidence but yet it's not as if it's
clear that this phenomenon is replicable
and so i don't see why it's so hard why
is it that the system won't allow
the paranormal or remote viewing to be
proved
or to be shown to be true with more
evidence
that there's just huge amounts of
evidence it's just that you don't look
for it
because you assume that there isn't
there's lots of evidence there's
lots of people doing um
you know doing remote viewing very
seriously there's
you'll find just go go look for it and
you'll find that there's lots of
evidence out there if you're looking for
evidence read then
dean raiden's books he talks lots of
experiments
all those things are just exactly the
way he says they are
he's not a goofball you know doing crazy
stuff he's a he's a smart guy and he's
very careful
about his science he sees himself as a
scientist doing these experiments
so there's lots of proof there's lots of
stuff out there
that's not a problem there's a skeptic
his name is randall randy right he has
some bridesmaids
right right so why hasn't that been
claimed i don't understand
well that has been claimed but it's
never been paid
so that's if you're looking for a scam
that i would classify as a scam so
you know that's a that's politics that's
a
that's showmanship that's not that he
actually intended to give any money away
it was just a um you know one and a i
guess a salvo and
propaganda wars you know all of these
things
perhaps it had to be that way because if
the person was able to claim the prize
then the system
should not have given that person the
answer because as you're mentioning with
the lottery
there's there's been there have been
people who have done
what they said they would do things that
just kind of showed that you know
they did paranormal things or whatever
there's not that there's lots of people
can do
those things and
most of them probably are just amateurs
at it so if you put them on stage and
make ever you know put a lot of people
watching they may
their intellect gets in the way their
fear gets in the way
but there's um there's plenty that can
under stress can
perform pretty flawlessly and
some of those took randy at his word and
randy basically
said no must have been a trick i don't
know what the trick was but it must have
been a trick somehow you don't win
so it's not really a a real thing
randy and other people who call
themselves skeptics
that's their belief their belief is that
it's impossible
and they'll go to great lengths to try
to push that belief
forward but they're not really skeptics
at all
they're just believers and they're just
believers and
that it isn't possible and they're
trying to convince others
to believe what they believe so i very
much
am a skeptic and i encourage everybody
to be skeptical
just because you are talking to somebody
in the non-physical
you need to be very skeptical of
anything you get
maybe you just made it up remember you
are consciousness and you can create
information
and when you get something you get a
data stream
part of that data stream could be
because you created it
that's the daydream right you can create
data
or it could come from the system or it
could come from some other
individual all consciousness is netted
we're all connected we can open and
close connections to other
consciousnesses
they can send things to us so there's
only three
possibilities it comes from the system
it comes from some other iuc you make it
up yourself
and there's no tags on any of that you
know it's not like one comes in blue and
the other comes in red
it's all just information and we get all
that information sometimes all three of
them scramble together
and you can't say for sure for certain
where it comes from
it can be coming from you as a
possibility
with experience you get you do
know more what's yours and what's not
when things come to you and they
surprise the heck out of you because
you just don't have that idea in your
mind
then you know that you just get it's
it's obvious to you that that came from
outside of you and if that happens many
many times and you know things turn out
to be correct and you can remote view
and you can heal all the stuff then
then the idea of is this real is it
coming from outside of me and i'm making
it all up well you're not going to heal
somebody if you're making it all up
you're not going to remote view you're
not going to be very successful getting
the picture
elements right if you're just making it
all up so
you can convince yourself that it's real
but you have to convince yourself
that it's real and nobody else can
convince you
and matter of fact people like you and i
who are very
left brain dominant because we're
science guys
we are very hard to come to the we're
very
difficult to come to the conclusion that
it's real i was working with bob
and probably had you know one in a
hundred thousand at the things that i
was doing was just good luck you know
i'm a good guesser you write a ten digit
number on the board and i'm just good at
guessing it
you know well if you do the the math you
can keep track of
of the statistics and it was a
you know an extremely extremely
extremely unlikely
that i was doing what i was doing just
by good luck you know people just got
to get healthy after i worked on them
and things like that so i had lots and
lots of evidence
but i still didn't believe it in my mind
well
i don't know how it works therefore it
could be something very
mundane that i'm just missing so
i ten and most left-brained people tend
to be
very hard to convince that
it's real there is something real out
there that's
outside of you that you can interact
with
and it interacts with our reality but
the thing that took me over the top was
when i went
with dennis on that outer body together
and it was taped
and there was a tape of everything
dennis said and a separate tape of
everything i said
and you play those tapes together
synchronize them in time and dennis and
i are talking back and forth to each
other in conversation
well that's kind of hard to fake that if
you're making it up
you know that's really really hard so
after
that and we saw the same things we
talked to the same beings
and that was that was the thing that got
it out of my mind down to the bean level
after that i didn't ask anymore is it
real
even though intellectually i knew it was
real
what a hundred thousand to one that i'm
a good guesser
now there's something else going on
there obviously
but i didn't let it
get to me at the bean level until way
later i was at bob's for probably a
couple of years before that thing that
that uh dennis and i did that made me
feel it's real
so i suspect you'll be the same and so
well most everybody else it's a
you know that's a techie takes a lot for
us to
change our fundamental view of the
nature of reality
we need proof we need a lot of evidence
and it should be that way
you should be skeptical you meet some
being out there and they said oh yeah
this is god talking and what i want you
to do is go shoot those people
you know like some crazy people do and
you got to be skeptical you got to say
whoa
no thank you just because
something talks to you and tells you
that they're god isn't a reason to
believe a word of it
you know you always remain skeptical of
everything you get
and only slowly do you collect enough
evidence that you can
that you no longer worry about you know
is it true or not
do ufos fit into your theory in any way
or aliens yeah in a in kind of a
sideways
way they do um we live in a virtual
reality
so anything that is in your reality is
just a matter of information in your
data stream
um if it would you know if you
and your five friends are all standing
out on the balcony of your house and a
flying saucer comes down and lands in
your yard and little green men come out
and wave to you get back in their ship
and fly away
and all five of you saw it well how
could that happen
well if you're a materialist then you
have to imagine that there's aliens and
they live someplace and they have high
technology and they can build ships and
they flew there and they landed in your
yard
but if you realize it's a virtual
reality you can say oh somebody put that
in my data stream
it's just data reality is created by
data in a data
stream what about people like bob lazar
who said that they worked on craft and
the craft operate on interesting physics
which seems to imply that it does have a
material basis at least for aliens
or their craft well lots of things have
a
you know a material basis you say
most of that is done in their minds
most of that is not done in their
with their physical selves it may sound
that way but that's
mostly all mental they get there
in their minds they make that connection
with their minds they see that lab with
their minds
and they they maybe look at technology
so it's
it's that kind of a thing it's
consciousness meaning that the
u.s government doesn't house it and it's
just in bob lazar's mind or
that all the people in that facility are
collectively getting data from the same
stream
now it's i'm not sure now we got a
facility involved
we did have just one in one individual
yeah what i meant was that
bob lazar was someone who at least he
claims to have worked at a facility near
area 51 i think it was called s1
he was a particle physicist before and
he was recruited by the
united states government to come work on
some top secret project when he got
there and he saw the craft
he said he actually chuckled himself
because he said oh look it's just
u.s technology and that's what people
are in a clamor about when it comes to
saying that ufos exist because he was
one of those people who thought the ufos
doesn't exist so he's like okay well
here's the
explanation then when he got to working
on it more and more
he realized this is a technology that we
don't have and that it operates
by what he calls gravitational wave
amplification
which is not something that we possess
yeah
i would be very skeptical of that
because i'm skeptical of everything
so i would advise anyone to be
very skeptical of that now
aliens in general are something that's
outside of our normal reality right
that's that's a
that's an outside thing so for people to
think that there are aliens sneaking
around and doing things and having
conversations with aliens
that's a mind opener into a reality
being bigger than what we just thought
it's not just what we see and what we
hear what we read and what we study in
science but it might be bigger than that
well that's a positive thing in as much
as it cracks
the mind open a bit to bigger
possibilities than just the stuff that's
standard and that's a good thing
so i can see that the consciousness
system
in order to crack those minds open might
be using aliens as
a way of doing that so that's
that's one thing okay so so
yeah it's like that but that doesn't
mean
that there are uh tom i gotta get going
i gotta get going to my massage i'm
gonna
all right go i'm gonna try out some of
the techniques
you know we could go on like this for
weeks but uh
i suspect did you get your two questions
answered oh
i definitely got my two questions
answered okay thank you okay
good well i'll see you later go get a
massage
thank you my friend and i appreciate you
being so generous with your time and i
appreciate you helping me
through this i know that i give the
impression that i'm a close-minded
intellectual but i wouldn't be talking
to you if i was
and i think if you knew some of my views
you'd be somewhat astonished
because well let me put it this way
i'm not convinced materialism is correct
nor
not correct and same with the multiverse
same with wolfram's theories
same with yours i'm sorry but i don't
know what's true
and so when i do my meditation i do go
in with the intention of not
having an intention i just go because i
want to see i want to feel
and you mentioned that maybe that could
be holding me back maybe i should go in
with a bit more of a focus
but then i am an intellectual and so it
would mess with it but either way i just
wanted you to know that and the only
reason i didn't correct you at any time
is because i didn't want it to seem like
i'm defensive about it
and it's and also i don't it doesn't
matter too i also
want to see where would you go with that
were you gonna say that i'm more of a
a physicalist or a duelist or a
non-dualist and i was just curious so
i'm poking at you because i'm poking at
myself i don't know
but i'm not trying to be falsely humble
and say i don't know all the answers
like some people
i don't know the answers but i'm not
going to claim that i don't know all the
answers because
people who do that are virtue singular
are virtue signaling when they do that
either way that's where i stand and i
it's a good place to stand look you're a
seeker
you're trying to find the truth and you
will
if you keep searching if you put the
time into it if you make an effort
if you're serious about it you will get
there
and there's there's only one truth but
there's thousands
of paths that'll get you to that truth
yeah so
just work on it and the things that work
for you
do those the things that don't work for
you let them go
and you will eventually end up at that
one truth that you keep after it
one question that occurs to me now and
hopefully you can answer it briefly
i know that it takes quite some time but
one question is when you mentioned that
we're this consciousness and we're
logged onto the game and that ordinarily
we identify with the avatar of the game
and that that's a mistake and what we
should identify with because it's true
at least in your theory sorry to put
quotation marks around it at least it's
true in your theory that this is who we
truly are the consciousness above that's
logged on
then you said that when we die well some
parts of our memory i'm not sure if some
parts are all but
regardless let's not harp on that some
parts of the memory at least
continue on as well as with your choices
whether you've done good or bad
or evil or lower entropy or raised
entropy or however you would like to
word it
what i'm wondering is is that supposed
to bring someone comfort i hear some
people say this plenty
i hear some of the people who are on the
more vedic ends of the tradition
that say well your consciousness does
continue on
past your death now on the western end
they'll say your consciousness continues
but you go to a place whereas
on the more eastern end if your
consciousness continues but it's not you
it's not your ego
it's something else but then what i'm
wondering is the eastern side doesn't
seem to provide at least someone like me
it doesn't provide me with any comfort
because that
me that me the player that's logged on
bears so little resemblance to who i
identify with now
that it would be just like a materialist
trying to give me hope by saying
well all your molecules are going to
continue on anyway so technically you do
live on you're breathing the sun from
you're breathing the big bang so you
are like i'm like okay well i see that
but it bears
so little resemblance to what i
conceptualize as my identity
i don't give you a lot of comfort either
that that free will awareness unit we
talked about before
that's the part that's really logged on
that's the piece of the iuoc
individual unit of consciousness that's
that's logged on to the avatar
that's a one-off when after that life is
done
that that partition's taken down it's
integrated back into the individual unit
of consciousness
and now a new petition gets put down
with just
what it's been learned and that goes off
and logs on so
all of those petitions all those free
will awareness units are
just one-offs when they're done they're
done
but what you accumulate is all of your
experience all your growth all of your
learning
all of your quality all of your
entropy reduction that is accumulated
and you have a database it's not memory
but you have a database of
of all the things that you've done all
the thoughts all the feelings
what about your friends what about the
relationships are those also cataloged
because i could imagine that even if
somehow i am to continue on
with my attributes but if i don't have
the people that i love
around me and i'm not able to recognize
them at least then that also is somewhat
meaningless
at least to me at least right now yeah
that's because where you are now
and you know the way you see life and so
on and
an ego that wants to continue on as you
and wish to continue on those
relationships because you know your
children
your wife you know there's people who
are dear to you and you want that to
continue on
it doesn't that's that is here when you
die
your awareness of your life here begins
to fade like a dream
and you don't continue that it's it's
not practical
yes that's kind of soft and warm and
it's comforting
but it doesn't work that way because it
isn't
functional it doesn't work so let's say
here you are and you've been through ten
thousand lifetimes and you've had uh ten
thousand sets of parents's you've had
thirty thousand children whatever and
you're going to remember all those and
want to
do something with all those
relationships or is it just the last 20
or the last 500 you know it doesn't work
that way
that just is going to wide you up into a
big ball
of of uh stuff that is emotionally
grabbing at you and it's not going to be
functional at all
each time you take what you've learned
you graduate from third grade and you
take what you've learned
and you go into fourth grade and it's a
new experience new teacher
new subjects expect you to know new
things
so you it's that comfort of you being
you
well it's only a problem if you see you
as curt if that's you in your mind as
kurt
then you have this problem but of you in
your mind
is your individuated unit of
consciousness the collector of all the
experience if that's you
then you lives on forever and it's not a
problem
you realize that these relationships you
have now as meaningful as they are
they happen because those are the people
you ran into if you're born on the
opposite side of the planet uterine
you'd run into different people and next
lifetime you're going to run into
different people
too and most of your learning comes from
these relationships they're very
important
they're very significant but
you know so is your third grade teacher
significant but you don't make her come
along under the fourth grade with you
it's done it's
so yeah that's that's a cold prickly
kind of thought to a lot of people who
see themselves as their
body they want that body person to
continue and all those relationships to
continue
because that's kind of warm and and
whatever and
i guess christianity tends to tends to
satisfy that warm fuzzy feeling some
because
that's something a lot of people like
you know it's a very attractive thing to
offer
but that's that's um and islam yeah
that's not how it
that's not really how it works it's not
practical it's not logical
the system you know i didn't put
reincarnation in my system because i
thought it was a really cool idea in the
buddha like that you know i
put it in there because it was logically
necessary for the system to work
and okay okay oh man there's one bit
i i know i gotta go and i know i keep
getting you but here's what here's
something that
if i'm being honest here's something
that always
i guess it's like a splinter in the mind
to use the
term from the matrix with when i was
reading your book it's at
times there's a denigration of thinking
of the world in a traditional sense
because aoun
aum is so outside of what we can fathom
it's so enigmatic but then at the same
time there seems to be a selective
applying of certain principles
that we can fathom here so let's say you
use some entropy analogies or you use
the word logic but even logic
itself there's para consistent logic
there's classical logic there's
intuitionist logic that's not clear
so then i'm like well why is it that auo
if one was to apply the traditional man
in the sky or if one was hindu
brahman brahma or brahmin and we are
just part of the infinite dreams of
brahmin
then those are to be destroyed as well
as other formulations like it's a
consciousness that we can even conceive
of
or that there are physical laws that
i think you understand what i'm saying i
don't understand what you're saying yeah
and i would tell you that these are all
these are all different models
and these models are basically built
with metaphors
all of my model is metaphor the larger
conscious system is a metaphor for
source
uh you know individual unit of conscious
is a metaphor free well awareness unit's
a metaphor
all these things are metaphors for
functions of consciousness that are
necessary
in order to model consciousness
accurately so that's what they are
other other there are other models
around and these other models have their
own metaphors
and their own tool sets things they make
up tools or things that you create
could make it easier to understand so
there's all sorts of models around
and i would tell you that to be a seeker
stay
skeptical and see how it works for you
where does it take you and that's how
you decide not with your intellect
but by trying it becoming it
living it thinking about it
but applying it not just thinking not
just coming up a bunch of intellectual
stuff inside your head that you can
contrast and compare
that's not going to really help you
learn anything you need to actually
walk that path do those things and see
how does it feel what are you learning
what are you getting from it you walk
that path for six months and
are you a better person now do you feel
good a year from now
after that when you get to the point you
say no i'm not really changing any it's
not really doing that much for me then
go someplace else thousands and
thousands of different paths that all
will take you to the same place as long
as you stay
open-minded and skeptical you will
always get
to the end point you'll make it it may
be a circuitous path but you will make
it
so just go do experience be
don't just think about it don't keep it
all in your head
and then ask the question
is it helping am i better is my life
better am i happier are my relationships
better is it working
in the book i say taste the pudding and
if it's working for you do more of it
when it stops working for you
do less of it go somewhere else
okay that sounds like a great place to
end it man
thank you so much again for your extreme
generosity and i gotta get going
i'm a bit late but have a great one man
i appreciate it
hey never be late to a massage
i'm going to read some thoughts thomas
campbell was one of the most highly
requested guests on this podcast
so i try to be as thorough as possible
i'm interested in the truth
though plenty of people consider him to
be pseudoscience
i think that's unfair while i get plenty
of praise for interviewing jeremy
corbell
on ufos there were quite a few who
disliked the subject matter being
broached
i happen to dislike anathema's if you're
telling me that there's a realm of
knowledge that should be limited to a
certain sphere
and it's disallowable to explore what's
outside that sphere
then i'm immediately skeptical let me
come to my own conclusions
you're watching this because you want to
come to your own conclusions
and that's wonderful that's great those
open-minded and exacting
individual thinkers that's what this
channel is about that's who it's for
my final thoughts are pretty much that i
have my gripes i'm not convinced that
he's anywhere near to deriving the
fundamental laws
of physics mathematically i see his
theory as being so vast
that whatever the mathematical nature of
our laws do turn out to be
it can still be incorporated into his
model because auo
which is absolute unbounded oneness is
so much like a blank parchment
and ink that whatever equations you
write on it
the auo can say well yes i predicted
that because that's
pen on paper i'm not saying anything
that i haven't said to thomas or
wouldn't say to thomas campbell
but again this is all for you to decide
on your own i'm just giving you my own
thoughts
in many ways i'm still simply a
cretinous imbecile who knows nothing
and i don't think i'm capable of
articulating thomas's theory
back to him in a way that he would agree
which means i don't understand it which
means i'm not in a position to judge it
yet
okay that's that i have to get some rest
i have to eat i have to break my fast
have a good night and of course please
let me know your thoughts
i hate to say this because i'm not i
don't consider myself to be a youtuber
but if you're not subscribed please
subscribe
and hopefully i can keep up the level of
quality in the podcast